we have a text thread
that is called Keanu forever
for Keanu Reeves yeah okay how did that
start we're all in the same age range
and we grew up on Keanu I mean come on
it's Keanu so I was in the air in a
elevator with him and when he got on the
elevator I was like oh my God this is
I'm gonna I'm about to get married I was
like oh my God and I was like okay well
I could say hi or I could just wait for
him to say hello
and then I was going back and forth and
then the doors opened and he walked out
nothing happened no I didn't even say hi
I didn't even say hello I love you
um I've Loved You Forever
um my name is Jersey I would like to
have babies with you I mean
I don't say anything